bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france l'heure
n'est pas au bilan un paraît-il un nous
dit jean castex mais alors quand et sur
quelles bases élevées ne mettront
peut-il faire campagne alors oui c'est
en me dable avec la république en marche
et que l'heure n'est jamais vraiment au
bilan toucher toujours à la
communication alors si c'est pas le
bilan maintenant il faut attendre
quelques maquereaux et décidé de faire
son bilan pour le moment il a décidé de
faire son auto promo on l'a vu trois
jours à marseille d'une auto promo
incroyable où il sortait le carnet de
chèques des français pour dire qu'il
était le sauveur de la ville là en ce
moment c'est à peu près paraissait des
jeunes avec le maquereau qui s'y colle
qui collent des affiches voilà macro
président des jeunes or les sondages
disent à peu près tout l'inversé on a vu
depuis la crise sanitaire les jeunes
faire la queue auprès des banques
alimentaires bien sûr la réduction des
apl l'entrée dans la précarité un jeune
sur cinq qui a abandonné ses études en
fin de bilan est catastrophique donc il
faut faire de la communication c'est un
peu la réalité alternative à la trump
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où on
va dire des choses on va y croire et
peut-être même que les électeurs les
français vont y croire alors allons-y
pourquoi faire un bilan quand on peut
faire de la com alors pourtant avec 6 e
on voit une activité bouillonnant
rentrent sains à la république en marche
en ce début septembre qu'est ce que ça
signifie
alors ben encore une fois occupé
l'agenda médiatique être là tout le
temps parce qu'en fait la république en
marche ne tient que par emmanuel macron
donc une fois c'est le champion qui est
là pendant trois jours à marseille et
après hop retour au parti aujourd'hui
ils étaient tous pour la rentrée
parlementaire arrangé pour parler se
mettre tous au diapason ses députés de
la république en marche avec que
stanislas guérini qui disait quand même
il y un bilan attention le bilan du
quinquennat c'est plus d'impôts pour les
gaffes à plus de congés pour les papas
voilà c'est à peu près les deux seuls
plus alors l'idée c'est 50 plus avec ces
slogans pour dire que macron c'est un
peu monsieur plus celui qui a fait le
plus pour la france alors il ya aussi
bas faut pas oublier il ya eu des
violences lors des manifestations des
gilet jaune il ya eu aussi la casse des
droits sociaux il veut revenir encore
sur la réforme des retraites pour dire
que c'est un président réformateur parce
que finalement de réformes il en a eu
très peu donc on voit bien qu'il est un
peu coincé par le temps change jours
pour agir donc c'est ce qu'ils veulent
faire il ya ensuite
l'université d'été si on peut dire
puisque ce sera début octobre de la
république en marche à avignon arrivé
après les autres là encore pour occuper
l'espace médiatique et puis on voit les
équipes 1 qui s'installe avec à un
débauché de chez orange qui va prendre
en charge la campagne de du candidat
macron quand il sera déclarée et le
siège bien sûr le nouveau siège parisien
la république en marche puisque c'est un
parti ridja ils ont beaucoup de début et
donc aider le député parce que en
réalité très peu d'élus locaux mais ça
leur permet d'avoir un trésor de guerre
pour préparer cette campagne en tout cas
l'opération comme maranger a été plutôt
voilà assombri si je peux me permettre
de me permettre par la mort de jean-paul
belmondo dont on a davantage parlé
certainement alors il n'y a pas que
l'arrêt main où on assiste à une
communication politique intense en ce
début de rentrée encore plus de
candidats et de candidates oui alors
c'est la rentrée politique évidemment
mais alors comme on en a les
présidentielles c'est un peu tout et
n'importe quoi ça foisonne arnaud
montebourg à clamecy qui arrive après
cette parenthèse d'entrepreneuriat où il
pourtant il disait à peu près chaque
année qu'il avait fermé la parenthèse
politique que plus jamais il n'y
reviendra bon ben c'est un peu comme
roselyne bachelot avec qu'on leur
propose un truc ou dès que c'est une
année présidentielle on y va alors pour
un an montebourg a aucun candidat n'a de
programmes et pourtant il repique à peu
près toutes les idées de l'avenir au
coma la plate forme programmatique de la
france assouvissent de jean-luc
mélenchon il essaye on a aussi anne
hidalgo à gauche qui fort de son bilan
la mairie de paris bilan contesté 1 et
bien elle veut aussi se lancer dimanche
prochain lors d'un jt pour annoncer sa
candidature elle prépare ses équipes à
la mairie de paris et puis il ya la
primaire des écolos alors là ça discute
et l'idée c'est de faire oublier un peu
la primaire parce qu'il faudrait qu'un
candidat émerge mais c'est compliqué
entre sandrine rousseau eric piolle
yannick jadot delphine batho et tous ces
mouvances 1 2 de l'écologie et puis à
droite alors là c'est
une énorme question ils étaient réunis
au parc floral ce week-end et la
question c'est qui ce qu on fait des
primaires sous quelle forme comme en
fait et alors qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
xavier bertrand qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec valérie pécresse et puis eric
ciotti qui avec sa sortie disons qu'ils
seraient prêts à voter pour les xénons
alors même qu'ils récusent et nous on
n'est pas candidat sème le trouble et
bien sûr eric zemmour lui se lance par
contre dans une campagne d'auto promo à
partir de la mi septembre pour vendre
son livre sous forme de programme donc
il y aura peut-être d'autres surprises
dans cette course à la présidentielle ça
ne fait que commencer et le fait on
continuera avec vous évidemment alexis
poulain merci à vous